whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up u.s.
senator Blanche Lincoln for trying to
ban betting on box office sales you can
collect for eg posters when you buy a
Macdonald happy meal and happy meals
turned sad in California's Santa Clara
County when this politicians plan to ban
toys from kids meals became law we're
talking a very serious health issue but
there's only one nanny of the month and
this time it's Scott hunter chief of the
North Carolina State Capitol Police
there's a new rule at the Capitol
limiting how people could go about
carrying their American flags flags like
this are just fine under the new rule
hunter cooked up just before tax day but
flags like this uh uh
in fact protesters may not carry flags
or signs attached to poles or posts more
than a foot long you see officials fear
that could be used as weapons as a sight
to measure safety measure is right
because there's no telling what these
Tea Party people might do ultimately the
rule was suspended before April 15th and
funny thing is there were no flag
related stabbings check back next month
for more examples of busybodies minding
your own business